[INTERPOSING VOICES]
I didn't mention
your [INAUDIBLE]..
Interstitial.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
Doesn't just [INAUDIBLE].
I used him [INAUDIBLE].
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
You can't progress,
no [INAUDIBLE]..
[LAUGHTER]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
So you know what I'll do?
I'll just do this.
I'll just mute, mute
[? the image. ?]
Yes, we think about 15
minutes [INAUDIBLE]..
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[INAUDIBLE] Q&A mic.
OK.
[INAUDIBLE]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
OK.
All right.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
Hello, hi.
You don't all have to wave,
but a couple of waves are nice.
Thank you for being here.
My name is Evan
Ziporyn and I'm very
happy to be the director of
MIT's new Center for Art,
Science, and Technology,
and even happier
to be able to welcome
our guest for the week.
Actually, the first
and inaugural artist
brought here as part of
the center, Tomas Saraceno.
And we are just, as a center,
getting up and running.
My co-director is Leila Kinney.
And I also want to thank Liz
Murphy who produced this event,
and Anya Ventura who did a
lot of the writing to generate
interest to get you here.
It's been an incredibly
interesting and busy week
for Tomas.
I can't imagine he has
anything left to say,
but we're going to make him talk
for a couple of hours anyway.
Just briefly, you've been seeing
slides of some of the events
we have coming up in the spring.
I hope that you will
take note of these
and that we'll see you
for some or many of them.
I would just now
like to introduce
the host of this panel, Moving
Beyond Materiality, something
we all need to try to do.
The head of the
Department of Architecture
here at MIT, Nader Tehrani, and
he will bring out the panel.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Thank you for the introduction.
Good evening, ladies
and gentlemen.
Welcome to tonight's event.
It's a great pleasure
to be able to make
an introduction for
such an occasion,
as it represents
the best of MIT.
A place that not only
promises to mediate
between the arts,
sciences, and technology,
but in fact, to draw out
its greatest potentials.
I do want to also thank
Leila Kinney for making this
possible, and CAST
in general for making
this entire week possible.
CAST has been at the forefront
of many such opportunities,
and we in architecture
have benefited a great deal
from their broad
vision in helping
us to expand our culture.
This is great.
Before I introduce
tonight's speaker,
I would like to first welcome
Anton Garcia-Abril who
will, alongside me,
help to moderate and act
as interlocutor for the evening.
It is no accident that he
is here with us tonight.
Anton just joined the
faculty of architecture
and promises to bring great
maturity and sophistication
to the arena of design
and building technology
specifically within
our curriculum.
With his team and
ensemble and their POPLab,
Anton's presence
has already been
felt in the halls of
3rd semester core,
and we've all had
the honor of hearing
him speak about his
own work and research
for the open house
just two weeks ago.
Anton's presence is known
on the global stage,
and his work is widely
recognized for its invention,
its rigor, and play.
His focus on material agency
and its corollary methods
of fabrication have
brought new life
to ancient ways of conceiving
building protocols while they
have also brought new depth to
modern construction systems.
Of the many protean ways he has
operated on material systems,
maybe his reassessment of
masonry and concrete structures
remain the most
alarming and seductive.
In an era where we can only
conceive of stone as veneers,
as finishes, or as ornaments,
Anton has brought new weight
to the medium.
His Music Studies
Center, The Truffle,
and the SGA headquarters
are but three examples
that bear witness to the
astonishing ways in which
his studio has reinvigorated
a discourse on stereotomy,
on the monolithic,
and on the colossal--
not to mention the monumental.
While these were categories
previously reserved
for the arena of
history and theory,
looking back at the
Neolithic period--
or more recently, if you
like, towards the Romanesque--
I'm reminded of the way
in which all of this
was theorized by Rodolphe
el-Khoury in his book,
On the Monolith, in the 1990s.
Examining the way in which
contemporary buildings are
revisiting one of architecture's
core figurative strategies
to inspire complex ways of
transforming both building
culture, and perception today.
If anything, Anton's
work radicalizes what
el-Khoury begins to theorize.
Anton's own second
doctoral thesis revolves
around stressed mass,
bringing our attention
not only to the ways in which
engineering has advanced
structural agency,
but also how this
has enabled architectural
strategies that require mass
as the basis of
their transformation,
their communication,
and function.
Anton's architecture is
serious, but it's also deadpan.
There's no other way of
interpreting his Truffle,
especially in the way
that it is delivered
in his now infamous video
of its construction.
It has gravitas and weights,
metaphorically and literally,
but also the lightness
of being, which
brings us to the main
introduction of the evening.
Tonight's speaker,
Tomas Saraceno,
is an expert on lightness,
but with the same gravitas
and weight of our
interlocutor, Anton.
Saraceno's structures
are ephemeral,
they're intricate, immaterial,
and stubbornly light,
refusing to be subordinated
by the traditional mandates
of tectonics.
Not innocent to the
protocols of architecture,
this artist, if it
is OK to reduce him
to such a nomenclature,
is, in fact, an architect.
A graduate of the
Universidad de Buenos Aires
with a postgraduate degree
in art and architecture
in Escuela Superior de Bellas
Artes Ernesto de la Carcova.
And then, again, another
postgraduate degree
from the Staatliche
Hochschule in Frankfurt.
Tomas is, if anything,
overeducated in architecture.
Something that gave way to his
interest in the arts, but also
offered an alternative path
for architectural speculation.
And this is important.
I like to say that
Saraceno had to escape
the architectural
profession in order
to undertake a more
challenging and engaged
architectural practice.
But a practice that had as
one of its core ambitions
and motivations to
demonstrate the very power
of the architectural discipline
and its ability to transform
reality as we know it today.
I will not belabor an
analysis of his work.
He will have the time to
make his case himself.
However, it may help
to situate his work.
As everybody knows,
the architectural field
has itself opened up many
alternative practices
in the past two
decades, if not more.
With the installation becoming
one of its main protagonists,
having even been
institutionalized,
not only in various
curricula as we
have here, but also
memorialized in annual events
such as the PS1 Series.
The work of Saraceno may draw
attraction from this tradition,
but it also should not
be confused with it.
While his work is
parasitical to architecture,
its best function
is to challenge
the very institution of art and
architecture at the same time.
His most recent work in Milan on
spacetime foam is an exemplary
piece of work, in that
beyond the material nature
of the installation--
which is, in its own right,
quite sophisticated--
it is an assault on perception,
sensation, and effect
on the one hand, but
also on the other,
a challenge to the very
building type which is its host.
To the codes that
regulate the building,
to the social foundations that
form how we use that space
and how it's negotiated.
In the tradition of
Christo and Jeanne-Claude,
one could claim that the
work is not only invested
in the architectural, but
also in the political and
bureaucratic protocols that
define, limit, and give
potential to the
practice, whether that's
the practice of
architecture or art.
However, in the
hands of Saraceno,
these parameters are led
to dizzying and vertiginous
results beyond that
of his predecessors.
With a disarming
character, Saraceno
is not only at ease
with his imagination,
but also with that
of his collaborators.
A militant collaborator,
each project
is precisely composed
of a variety of players
from different disciplines--
from the arts, the sciences,
and way beyond.
He operates with
methodologies that
are at once systemic
in their questions,
but also open to empirical
speculation, research, failure,
and risk.
Each project is an exercise
that has not yet been
rehearsed or choreographed.
Much of it is tweaked
and recalibrated
on site with an eye
towards public engagement
and interaction.
His work awaits you.
With a repulsion towards
the decorum of tour guided
protocols, his
attitude is formed
around pure physical
engagement and negotiation,
as if to use architecture
and materiality
to challenge social convention.
And maybe, it is exactly the
frame of the art institution
that can offer the suspension
of disbelief to help radicalize,
not so much the mise
en scene of Saraceno,
but his veritable
commitment to inventing
new architectural frameworks.
So without further
ado, I have to say
it is hard to imagine a more
appropriate visitor to MIT
Culture for this
occasion, and please
help me to give a
warm welcome to Tomas.
[APPLAUSE]
Well, thank you
for the invitation.
It's working, yes?
The microphone?
Yes.
I have to go from the beginning.
Let me put it here.
One second.
And then--
Tomas, I lowered the mic.
You may want to bring
it to your height.
But I think so-- ah.
Hello?
Yes.
Now it's working.
And, no, a little bit like,
we said maybe the lights,
we will leave them
off a little bit.
If somebody want to sleep.
That's a good idea, no?
At least I don't see you.
But, OK, that's good.
No.
And then the other thing is,
like, I would like to say,
I mean, thank you for
all the beautiful week,
for all the beautiful words
that I have heard today
and during this week.
And I mean, the list of
things is, I would say,
really endless.
And how inspiring I
have been to be here
and still what is to come.
But nevertheless,
I mean, I think
today is a little bit,
I will try to say,
like it's more like, again,
a kind of experiment.
Let's say, I don't like to
make presentation and try
to explain my work.
Or it's more about maybe
what had come up to you
and what you can
imagine about it.
Maybe it's a trigger of
some kind of imagination.
But I think that all of us
have somehow here or there.
And then it's like maybe the
capability to build something.
And somehow together.
You know, I always
thought like, I mean,
I kind of like to put
[INAUDIBLE] myself
in this case.
You know, I know I have to
stick it to half an hour.
This means it is now 6:52.
I have to get there.
But I have like, I
think, some 400 slides.
I always thought like
a way to interact
between me which is here, which
is kind of somehow boring,
also, but it's to give to all
of you kind of a remote control.
And then we know that in half an
hour, we have to go through it.
And this means when you start
to get bored about what I'm
talking about, it's
like if all of you
kind of click the
button, you know
I will be forced to try
to talk something else.
And then it will be like kind of
a very fast forward interaction
between what you
want me to talk,
or at least, there
might be something
related to the images.
But yeah, I have to
maybe find next time
like so many remote controls.
But going back a little
bit, and maybe, this
means any time, also.
I mean, let's try--
I don't know if it
work-- but maybe there
is a way that you can, I
mean, that was the [INAUDIBLE]
to put down the light.
Not that I don't
see you sleeping.
But you can say, hey,
come on, hurry up,
or whatever is going there.
But I mean, the first sample,
maybe, is a little bit,
which is in the same language.
I'm trying to kind of give
this long introduction.
It's about this work,
which somehow, it's
kind of a closed loop, feedback
loop, or kind of ecosystem.
Which somehow the wind turbine--
oh!
It work also like this.
But when I put up--
he promised the microphone will
work in any position anyway.
[LAUGHTER]
When the propeller is spinning,
somehow it charge the battery.
And the battery, it
make run the camera,
and the camera take pictures.
And somehow, you know,
it's like the first kind
of complicated thing, it's like
you want to take a picture of.
That's a good frame to
start the kind of a movie
or whatever it might be.
And but actually,
there is no wind.
This mean that will not be
picture, which will be running.
Because, basically, every time
that kind of one of the blades
go through these magnetic
sensor, it's take a picture.
This means, you know,
is a kind of more,
like, exercise to try to be
myself, maybe more patient,
or be surprised by things
that I'm not able to see
or to perceive.
And it's all about this
kind of extension or delay
which, somehow, the
[INAUDIBLE] [? source ?]
would give me the possibility
to reinterpret something.
I mean what has happened at the
end of the day is like, it's
like basically a time
lap, but it's based
on the wind and the wind power.
Which, by the way, also
give energy to the system.
But for example,
you see the moon,
kind of very smooth going here.
Then it go very fast, the moon.
And then the moon disappear.
And then appear somewhere
else in the scene.
Because there was no wind,
right, for a period of time.
This is always going to be
at this stage, wind-based,
the movie.
And, you know, I'm always
kind of curious somehow
to where now in the
newspaper appear
kind of, how was the glacier,
I don't know, in the '60s,
but the level of the
ice was much higher.
And the picture which
was taken at that moment
was not conscious on the
idea that now the ice
is kind of melting.
Does it mean there
is kind of archival,
or at least that
kind of an attempt,
that maybe I'm taking a picture
of something which somehow, I
do not take the
decision to see this,
but somehow, maybe the
wind took the decision
to document this for the later.
Maybe in a couple of
years I will be able
that something you don't
think might change somehow
it change later.
But anyway, we go to.
Yeah, this is Bolivia.
This is the the Salt Lake.
And again, I think
what happened here
is, again, I was not prepared
for what had happened, somehow.
I mean, and I let
your imagination also
to follow again.
I mean, what had
happened at night.
I mean, that's a nice image.
And it's OK.
Anyway, I was doing
a video again, here,
based on the system that I
was trying to explain before.
But during the night, you know,
it was not enough sensibility.
But what had happened, well,
we were sleeping up here
for almost a month on the lake.
And then most of the
time, also, there
is this kind of foggy situation.
And then as you can see, there
is some wrinkles in the water.
It kind of, I mean, the
deepness of the stars that you
see reflected down in
the sea, in the floor,
it's kind of pretty amazing.
It's like a super
perfect mirror.
Or you think oh, the
mirror, you will not
give the deepness of
the constellation.
Somehow you step like
this, and then you're all,
I mean, in the South hemisphere
you say three Marias,
and it kind of start to wrinkle.
I mean, there is a kind of
pretty much immersion, somehow.
And there is,
somehow also, let's
try to maybe read this
kind of reverberation
or this kind of movement
that somehow maybe we
try to interpret through
some other samples and work.
That's good.
Well, and then back in
this installation which
is in Italy, which is
how it happened the same,
maybe it happened in the
Salt Lake with the stars.
But in this case, it
happened with other people.
What did happen here is--
let me go back in this one.
I mean, you know, besides
like, you know, if I move now,
you will be moving.
If you move I will be moving.
And then this kind of
sharing of the space
or the possibility to move
and be moved by somebody
who you don't expect.
But I think so the more
it kind of funny part
is like when somebody entering
the lower part in the entrance,
well, it's a big
pressurized space.
I mean, when you enter
in the lower space,
you know, you've got a
very, very strong wind
which comes to you, and somehow,
you don't know what happened.
But the people which are on
top, they say, close the door!
Because everything collapse the
system very quickly situation.
There is, again, you know,
there is the engagement
between the people which are
kind of on different levels,
but also with the
people which enter.
And somehow you don't realize
that how much the things are
related, but somehow it works.
And then the other thing, which
was kind of a nightmare, also,
is try to get the approval
of how to get it there.
Because, I mean, three layers,
when you put a lot of pressure
in the cube, which is 7,000
cubic meters of air, all
the three layers are squeezed.
I mean, I just explained.
I mean, I don't have a
better method of what--
lasagna, maybe.
I start to get angry.
But, you know, there is no
space in between all of them.
This means when you
enter with your own body,
you kind of open the space.
And as big as you are, or if
you enter between two person,
then you kind of bend the space.
You know, which drive kind
of a very simple relationship
with the theory of
relativity, of how much
you have a mass of
body somehow, all
people or planets will be kind
of bond one to each other.
But the more complicated
was to try to speculate that
if it gonna work or not.
Because when you have somebody
on top, for example, going to
squeeze.
Doesn't mean you have to
move to the other level.
And when you are here,
you squeeze the other one
which is below.
This means there is a
lot of synchronicity
between how people moves
and how much is affected.
I mean, I'm passionate
about the butterfly effect
and how we might relate
one to each other.
Yeah, here.
People up here.
I will not go back to that one.
But, well, this is a
drawing by Paul Davies
when he tried to talk
about spacetime foam more
on a quantic scale.
And, you know,
it's still kind of,
it is a dimension which
kind of fascinate me.
I try to understand it and maybe
to reinterpret in some way.
I mean, here is also, these
guys pretty much in trouble,
because they cannot go
out from the installation.
Again, there is a
lot of security,
which we try to avoid it.
But for these men to
go out, somebody else
has to go to the bottom
of the installation.
And then he will be lift up,
and then he can get a staircase
and go out.
It take a while, it'll
be, until you learn.
And then another thing which
happened, usually, I mean, I'm
pretty much, at the beginning,
when I was doing installation,
we tried to make a
manual of how to use it.
Because it kind of is
a constant learning
process for me and for the
people who somehow have to take
care.
But another thing
is, people usually
like to be together in a space.
But when you be together
in a space, it's kind of,
you really go deep.
Much more than these.
It's very difficult to escape
from these kind of black holes
situation.
There we are.
That was the first time
that I entered kind of alone
and this guy tried to
come and rescue me.
But I didn't disappear here.
Anyway, one of the
idea, and I think
it's also when I received
the invitation of MIT,
which somehow was a dream,
also, like a student.
You know, [INAUDIBLE],,
my former professor,
he always say, well, you
have to go and study.
And say, go to MIT.
Somehow I didn't make it, but
I'm so happy to be here today.
But then the idea,
I mean, the way
how we build these work,
these kind of membrane-- let's
put it in that way--
is like then later,
we might be able to fill
it up with hydrogen,
and then there will be float.
Right, well, these
floating islands.
And here it is, well,
something like this.
We are thinking maybe we could
go to the Maldives island,
which they said were
the best time would
be maybe 15, 20 years,
that they kind of sink now.
And then we are trying to
kind of coordinate them.
And then we were talking
today about the idea
to add some de-salinization
system, very, very primitive,
of how we might be able
to chill out up here,
but at the same
time drinking water,
and at the same time,
trying to talk or enlarge
the dialogue of the piece.
That kind of engaging, that
kind of situational insight,
and how we might confront
with another scenario which
have more maybe latent concern.
But nevertheless,
I mean, to go back,
I'm kind of enthusiastic to
try to think that this might
be one of the
clouds, or might be
one of the ideas of how we might
be able to shape or to think
about.
And I also, to
expand, [INAUDIBLE]..
We are on a spaceship Earth,
spinning around the sun.
And all the time, there
is this kind of idea
to expand the concept of
thinking like a cloud city
on kind of multiple scales.
And but also go back to
the interpretation of what
might be, where they might be.
But basically, what I'm
thinking very easily,
we were in the Department of
Planetary Earth and Science.
And then was kind of
pretty interesting, also,
the speculation.
That we would say,
because I mean,
my first question will
be, is it possible that
to kind of an
architectural scale?
Or kind of, I just borrowed the
classification of the clouds
to try to simulate
how it might be,
like a kind of style
in architecture,
like a Romanic
Gothic or whatever.
And say like, OK, Cumulonimbus
City, or Stratonimbus City,
or Cirrus, or whatever,
and try to see.
I mean, the question that I
posed [INAUDIBLE] was saying,
like, could we imagine
that if cities are built,
let's say each of these
[? fields ?] is a house,
and then we can kind of
agglomerate one to each other.
It's kind of a big
mobility of cities.
It might resemble clouds
as we see them today.
Does it mean it might move
these particles in a certain way
if we have neutral
buoyancy that somehow
may form as the clouds form.
Based, also, on the
decision that we
might have that we want to be
[? neighborhood ?] on the way
from here to South
America and then back,
you know, that we can
choose the path somehow.
And then we said,
like, maybe there
are some small chamber that we
can drive with some particle,
and see if this simulation
of this kind of understanding
of possible cloud seeding
might be on that way.
Well this is some of the
interior of the [? scalar. ?]
Also was pretty interesting
the conversation
of how these things
might come together.
Well, you know, I'm
very fond of the area
to try to promote, again,
the idea of the Biosphere,
the Biosphere 2 which was in
Arizona, and how we might be
able, maybe, to build
the biosphere again,
but in this case,
floating in the air.
And to scale-- well, that might
[INAUDIBLE] the situation.
Here in this case,
you're not trying
to collect with that kind
of flexible solar panel
in the middle, some
mylar fall on the side,
and somehow, when the
sun hit, it kind of
focus, or help to concentrate
the sun in the middle.
And then it keep going.
This is kind of more
structured of how I think.
So it could come together.
It's a little bit
more technical,
but each sphere which
somehow, what I'm finding out
is much more easy to use,
simple kind of geometry,
and then when you join
one to each other,
somehow it close the gap.
And then it basically
is the same concept
of a wheel of a bicycle
in three dimensions.
And when you pull them
all together, somehow,
and you can enter
inside, and kind of hop
in between the space.
It's not floating.
It's hanging on the
tree, but hopefully you
could get up in the future.
Well, this is kind of the same.
Also in this case
was more difficult
when the people are up there,
because they could not see,
really, what's going on there.
I mean when again,
you know, it's
all these kind of
pressurized spaces,
it's pretty challenging to
understand how the dynamics are
in between the people.
Well, and then I've
been working, then,
with the [INAUDIBLE] borrowed
from the [? Trinity ?] College
and University.
And, you know, I've been
obsessed quite a lot
on the idea of how spheres
pack one to each other and kind
of the optimization between
the volume and the surface,
and how we could manage
to, just to get to a scale,
maybe I try to go, oh,
how they could connect one
to each other.
Which, somehow, it go
back to the piece which
is now at the Metropolitan.
This a little bit
kind of larger scale.
In this case, a 22 meter each.
Here you go to the Met.
These were kind
of pretty smaller.
And all the time, you know, a
little bit of reference, also,
was like a sundial,
somehow, the work.
Which is somehow, you
know, when the sun
hit one of the mirrors,
somehow the sight
of this kind of impossible
huge solar clock
at the building
which are around.
And then we speculate
a little bit more,
kind of [INAUDIBLE] of
don't pity the astronaut,
which is usually make
very funny experiments
on the International
Space Station.
If he might be able to
see the sunlight also
traveling to that distance.
This mean I was pretty much
concentrated on the piece,
but at the same time,
how you might be able,
other people, to perceive this.
And this is, again,
you know, the position
of these reflective
surfaces was, again,
trying to bring back
these experience
from [INAUDIBLE] from Bolivia.
Where you kind of, it's a
kind of a challenge to try to
perceive how many
reality you can
see at the same time and move.
I mean to, bring kind
of a larger scale,
it was a little bit
to, I mean, basically
what he speculated is if we
have a 1.2 miles diameter sphere
with one degree of
temperature between the inside
and the outside, you might be
able to lift it up in the air.
Taking into account the volume
of the structure and all
the material.
This means it's pretty
important how big.
It's not that I'm
obsessed to do big things.
But somehow, if you want to try
to fly only with solar energy
and be up only by
the sun, it kind of
need to get a little bit big.
And then there is this
kind of speculation
to try to bring down the sun
when many spheres are connected
together.
I mean, the very simple example
is like, play with a laser
and see how it kind
of bounced back
and then you kind
of reach up there
and then try to get it, also,
in a kind of in another scale
of dialogue.
And the other reason is that
I'm partially from Argentina
and like to eat barbecue.
And I thought,
well, that would be
funny to have a kind of a
huge solar cooking on top
of the Met.
People could go there
and hangs the sausage
and they can go eat them.
And this is kind
of a solar cooking
that we are trying to cook a
chicken which is hanging out
there in the [INAUDIBLE].
Well, you get to
another dimension.
And here is, this is one
of these solar balloon.
Which is to say there are
not many built in the world.
These you can build it,
like, if you are two or three
people, one weekend,
for $300, you
can more or less, put
a man up in the air,
only by solar energy.
I mean, solar energy
is really the sun
who heat up the interior
of these polyethylene 50
microns is the normal trashcan.
I mean, this plastic
which is over there,
is kind of similar to this one.
Yeah, It's not more
thick than this.
It's even a little bit thinner.
And we tape it together.
And I think at the
moment there are
eight in the world who have been
built, based somehow on this.
This is a little
bit more particular,
because we use this
pentagon and hexagon, which
the idea to incorporate aerogel
to get more thermal resistant
and to be longer.
Because every time
there come a cloud,
which, somehow, I like to think
cloud city, but you go down.
[INAUDIBLE]
But the idea is also we will be
above the level of the clouds.
This means there is
a kind of, and kind
of more at a certain speed.
And you can regulate
the altitude, also,
opening and closing.
No, you got a cord
in the middle.
This means you can
up and down also,
let the hot air go through.
Here's the interior.
Where is the rope.
Your pull this, more similar
to a hot air balloon.
Well, this is kind of a project
which I'm part of somehow.
It's kind of a
collaborative, let's put it
to a platform, called Museo
Aero Solar at the moment.
It might change
to something else.
And that's kind of
funny statistic.
No, it costs more to cycle
back than to produce a new one.
[INAUDIBLE] 4,000
to [INAUDIBLE],,
which can then be sold for 32.
Oh, my god.
That's crazy.
Anyway.
Well, by the end, you know, they
end up in the vortex of Pacific
with all the plastic bag.
And but then what we
start to do is like a kind
of a collect plastic bag.
It's kind of the project
kind of grow, always, somehow
to a conversation.
And then you kind of tape them.
And then it goes up again with
the sun and different shapes.
And there are different
teams in different parts
of the world, which somehow,
sometimes we get together,
and then this kind of museum
collection of plastic bag
keep expanding.
And somehow, you know,
it's like there's always
kind of a different meaning
of how you might interpret it.
And also, the
capability to see kind
of a super commercial trade
name, how you'd get completely
decontextualized when you
travel to another country.
I would say example,
we were in France
and then, I don't
know, what is it,
a common supermarket
chain here in America.
What it will be?
Star Market.
Star Market?
Yeah, Star Market
is [INAUDIBLE]..
Oh, Target or something right.
You know, and then
you're in a country
that they've been
Target, Target, Target.
Seems like Andy Warhol seemed
like kind of another direction.
But he's somehow, you
know, even these kind
of completely popular
trade name when
the experience that I receive
is like we went to Paris,
and then somebody was
laying down there.
They say, wow, that's super
cool label record from the '60s.
It was Target in Colombia.
You know what I mean?
It's like, also
when you things kind
of super globalized
interpretation of things,
I think so.
And it always depends about
the distance that you see.
Because it's somehow
when you adapt this,
and I don't read anymore
the label, right?
And when it's flying
up there, also.
And mostly, you know, it's
about idea to reusing.
No, I mean, when the
museum went to Cuba, also,
they have a super
highly consciousness
of reuse the plastic bag, no?
And not maybe to recycle,
which is kind of different.
I mean, potentially
to the plastic bag
have somehow to last.
What that'll be
another project I
don't know if I
will end up here.
But what's more, there was a
competition in architecture
which, as they said,
have been formed
and then was the idea of
proposing a mobile clinic
for prevent HIV in Africa.
And then I thought, like,
well one of the methods
that today exist
is a condom, right?
And to be able to blow it up.
And then the idea that also
it could, somehow, reach also
some destination,
which sometimes
is difficult to be reaching.
At the same time, kind of
maybe engage the dialogue
in a kind of a different system.
You know, my father
was all the time
kind of working
for United Nation,
and I've been growing up
going to developing countries.
And the first thing
I thought, you know,
let's say the European will
arrive with a small track
and saying well, today,
we will talk about HIV
or how to prevent
it left and right.
And then it's like in this
kind of maybe cultural context,
you know, people, they do
not even talk about sex,
which is most of the case
in some of these countries.
I mean, imagine opposite.
Arriving on a huge, kind of,
and you don't know, even,
if it's a condom.
You know, it's kind of might be
kind of driving some attention.
People coming to the square,
getting up in the thing.
And it's like,
maybe engage people
in kind of another
level of conversation,
and how they could appropriate
or think about something.
These are [INAUDIBLE].
And maybe one of the, there was
a piece in Venice which somehow
start with the idea to kind
of reinterpret what mostly was
this idea, which I kind
of read all the time,
was about the idea of that many
scientists use, or writers,
or astrophysician
also, they always talk
about the origin of the
universe or the cosmic web
as the best analogy
that they find
is always your relationship
with a spider web.
And a three
dimensional spider web.
This means what
did happen is I got
a very simple focus [INAUDIBLE]
for Max Planck Institute.
We went there, we visit him,
we start to talk about him.
And they have done this thing
which is called the Millennium
simulation.
Which is that somehow the
more precise simulation
of the origin of the universe.
And then, kind of keep
actualizing all the time.
Well, what we did,
we just bought
like a kind of a black widow
who came to the studio,
and we put it inside a box.
Trying to think
that by reproducing,
or try to kind of rebuild a
three-dimensional spider web,
we might understand
something in relationship
of how the geometry of
the universe is done.
What we did any
one moment, also,
with Peter Jaeger from
the Senckenberg museum.
It's kind of famous that
acknowledges what we try to do
is kind of a hybrid also
between different spiders.
We put first the black widow
who make a kind of type of web,
then we took out the black
widow and we put a [INAUDIBLE]
on top.
And then was going
to force animals
which had a kind of
solitary, they're not social,
they do not build well together.
But how one species will build
a web on top of the other web.
And then was pretty interesting.
And then the arachnologists said
oh, that will be interesting.
Anyway, we got very concentrated
also try to build only one.
Here we are, computer
tomography, try to read it.
The thickness of the
spider web is 0.00.
It's 1,000 of a millimeter,
and the best machines
that we could find.
And I think that have
no best, not micro CT
scan, but kind of this scale or
the dimension of a spider web.
You cannot read it.
This means we start to ask
to a lot of laboratories.
And one of the more
specialized, if I'm not wrong,
is [INAUDIBLE] from a
university in Basel.
He's a very keen person
on understanding.
What they were
doing, try to also,
I mean, spider
webs, you can always
divide it in bi-dimension
and three dimension.
Kind of not very scientific,
but it's kind of used, always.
If it's never
bi-dimension because it
involves some variation.
But what we figured
it out that nobody
have ever scan a three
dimensional spider web, or kind
of digitalized, or
try to understand
more precise the merging
properties of a three
dimensional spider web.
This means, you know, the
exhibition was coming up.
You have to present it
in the Venice Biennale,
was this invitation,
and we couldn't
find even a method to
start to scan it for then
be able to rebuild it.
This mean one day what we
were doing-- ah, here--
was with the laser scan, just
illuminate one of the boxes.
And then when you
illuminate with a scans,
you can see exactly
the intersection point
with a laser and the web.
This is mean based
on these, then
we went to the
Technical University
in Darmstadt, to the
Photogrammetry Institute,
and then we asked
them to kind of help
us to make this photogrammetry
system where we will
take in parallel into machine.
I mean, this is a project we
took two years to realize this.
Was quite a long process.
Here are some of
the slides, yet are
all these parts of the scan.
And then even we were trying
to make many scripting
in the computer and
try to kind of connect
some of and the threats.
And finally, we have
to do it all by hand,
because it was never working
so properly, the scripting.
And then based on this,
then, what they did
was kind of somehow building it.
Mean we got this kind of
enormous amounts of numbers
and nodes and intersections.
And then, I mean, we
can drive then, later,
exactly how we do it.
But you know, every
time that there
is two or more lengths reaching
to a point, we put a vertical.
We print all the nodes on
the floor and on the ceiling.
This means we know exactly
where the nodes are happening,
and then we put a nylon line at
the high where the nodes are,
and then we start to
build from one node
to another node in here.
Because what had happened,
when you pull one thread,
this thread might
bifurcating three and then
four and then five.
This means it's very difficult
if you don't have the exactly
position on space all the time
where the nodes are located.
It's very easy then
to pull into the form
of the net in another position.
This mean the nylon
threads, and then you
have to navigate
through the web,
also, which was
pretty complicated.
Here you can see
mostly how was that.
No, it come from the
floor, and somehow start
to elevate up in a
three dimensional space.
Yeah.
Oh, it was endless work.
I mean, it was winter outside.
Snow.
And then we have
to heat up the--
and also, I mean, now I
think so, on Monday, I
meet somebody here at MIT
who specializes on spiders.
And I'm very
interesting to start
to see and to share
some knowledge
and maybe I can give them
the data of this spider web,
and then see how it's going.
Yeah, people were
able to enter, also.
What had happened later,
it's like, I mean,
there was many kind of
discipline working on it.
Each of them make their
own scientific paper
on the ones who kind of had
to develop kind of the system
to make the scan.
Peter Jaeger from the
Senckenberg Museum
presented a project in
a paper in a Congress
[INAUDIBLE] Congress of
acknowledging Poland.
And then when I
met Jim Clement, he
is responsible of a lot
of life science experiment
on the International
Space Station
when I was at NASA in 2009.
And he said, oh, you managed to
scan a three dimensional spider
web.
I said, well, yeah.
Why we don't send it to ISS, no?
And then I said wow,
that's fantastic.
Because somehow, in my kind
of send spider back to space
and see how.
Because before, it was not sent.
I mean, spider had been in space
in a microgravity environment,
but always bi-dimension,
never three-dimensions.
They could not
really study them.
They will not make sense,
maybe, to compare them.
But somehow also what I,
and then we supply this
and we keep going on.
Now, there is somebody
in Japan, which
is very obsessed about that
all kind of connection,
planar, and not happening in
a three dimensional space.
This means he's
writing another paper
on kind of a different
interpretation
of the same work.
But what somehow it kind of
all the time kind of fascinated
me is this idea,
you know, it's like,
had the most beautiful
talk with Jerry Friedman
the other day in his laboratory.
And it's something that
he all the time also say.
You know, like we know only
4% things that we have named.
96% still is black
matter or dark energy,
and all the rest, 4%.
The human, the planets,
the hydrogen, the helium.
And I mean, you may
know much better
than me what's going on there.
But somehow, the
analogy that people
have found to try to explain
the origin of the universe
is kind of a three dimensional
spider web, which somehow you
can find in every corner of our
house, which at the same time
was less studied, maybe, as we
know how the universe is done
somehow.
You know, I kind of like this
knowing, they are knowing,
they are knowing,
the analogy that
you find, also, it's
less known than what
you thought, also,
at the beginning.
Well, this will be
the papers, and, well,
and this is one of
the last images, where
we are kind of trying to build
again the space elevator based
on some ideas down there.
I think so, that's it.
I think so more or
less I made it on time.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[INAUDIBLE]
Do you have your mic on?
Oh, yes.
Anton, I will let you
lead the questions,
and then I will hold them back
from this side as you start.
OK, Tomas.
I think there's something
that you can't avoid.
Yeah.
You said you were
trained as an architect.
So that leaves us some
questions about your my point
of view main work environment.
You operate in
space, but you're--
Can you speak up, please?
You're erasing part
of the, let's say,
Vitruvian principles, no?
The gravitas,
firmatis, utilitas.
And in this reinterpretation
of our physical world
in that slide line between
what's distinguished--
our own vicissity and
the experience on these
borders where you operate.
My question is
that there's always
the presence of the exist
in the real space, no?
Somehow you need this presence
to express or to materialize
the immaterial.
[LAUGHS]
That's the question.
I think so, I get
more in trouble,
also, like to define
what is material
and what is not material.
Like maybe one step backward.
And then it's always
like, what is the process
that you could invent
yourself to kind of delay
this capability of perceiving?
And to try to take into
account which are the players?
And somehow, the
pieces somehow, also,
kind of trigger this idea
of extending my capability,
or maybe the capability
of the other ones,
of how much role it plays.
For example, in the
piece in Italy, I mean,
it's very simple.
But it's like, there are
some actors that put it
on more in the way of how Bruno
Latour tried to define how much
accountability of the
environment or in the--
I don't know.
I would just kind
of try to delay.
I mean, now I forgot the writer.
He was living in Argentina
for quite a long time.
But he all the time
said like, look,
if I managed to
concentrate on myself
for 30 minutes just
looking at this glass,
and now, and I do these
just to look at this,
my life will be
completely different.
And I completely agree on this.
It's like, how much
can I extend myself,
my ability to look
at something, right?
And this, it might change again.
And then it's like, I
don't know if I've really
answered the question,
but that's something
which can obsess me somehow.
But to some degree, it
begs the follow-up question
of who you think
your audience is.
Often as architects, you
operate in two worlds.
One, you build buildings for
the general public for people
to work in, to rebel
in, to demonstrate in.
In other words, it
has many publics.
But another level of
discourse, one could say,
is a meta-discourse.
You design for a
particular audience.
Even not even all architects.
You may be--
For spiders.
Or for people or, I don't know.
People who build
parallel universes.
I don't know.
Do you have an audience that
is internal to your circle?
Whether it's art historical
or whether it's architects,
but they are the bearers of a
certain discourse to which you
compete with, aspired
to, et cetera?
Not really, I think so.
And I hope I will never have it.
Like it's so
classified, somehow.
It's like all the time,
you know, I hope so.
How to say.
It's like, well, I always
think, I'm kind of always
fascinated you know how
internet have been invented.
And let's put it
like this membrane,
let's put it like it's more
like a platform for people
to kind of engage, maybe, in
the construction of something.
Which might be like a
kind of and architecture
I'm interested in, and
kind of a social space
who might engage people kind
of sharing some possibility
of thinking about something.
But the audience, I mean,
I'm audience all the time.
You know, I cannot
separate so much.
And also, I cannot separate
so much of disciplines.
I'm kind of much more
interested to kind of read
what is in between.
Or let's say I'm not
so much interested.
Oh, I'm an architect, an artist.
Well, what we have
in common more.
That we may operate
together and do something.
That's what strike me much more.
And what make us
do this spider web.
I mean, the [INAUDIBLE] might
be interesting, something.
I will have another sensibility.
But somehow, we could
collaborate all together
and manage to do it.
And each of us, then the
scientist made the papers,
and I do part of the exhibition
and something that is.
But the audience, in this
case, was very diverse.
And it was more
successful, let's say,
I will feel myself
with how much we
can engage in a kind
of a possible dialogue.
And that's what, for
me, is architecture.
Architecture, it's not like
the construction space.
Architecture, you
can say, expanded
to the construction of poetry.
The architecture of poetry.
The architecture of
a computer system.
The architecture
of a musical piece.
But you do make choices.
For instance, at
some point, you had
to decide whether the spider
web was this thin or that thick.
So there are certain
a prioris that
go with certain
specifications against which
you critique yourself.
And this invariably
involves a larger discourse.
So basically, I'm asking
how you insert yourself
into those critical
decision-making processes.
I never do them alone, somehow.
I hope so.
I mean, the first thing, why
we choose the black widow,
because at the
beginning, was supposed
to be the piece
which goes to Venice.
And the black widow have
a kind of configuration
which somehow have kind
of very [INAUDIBLE]..
I mean, all the [INAUDIBLE]
because we put the black widow
upside down how we present it.
Anyway, to see how spiders
are always, you know,
we have a kind of internal
discourse or dispute
about why the spider is
presented the opposite.
But first was, you know,
let's choose a type of spider
who the geometry also will
allow people to walk through.
And somehow will get entangled
somehow, but also it move.
Does this mean the decision
in that case was together
with Peter Jaeger.
Then this decision of
the material each--
Did the spider
determine the geometry,
or did you edit and
editorialize some of it?
No, we have many.
I mean, we have,
maybe, 15 or 20 boxes.
Does this mean in
some moment, yes, we
decided which one was
the more beautiful.
I mean, completely conscious.
And then also, when we try
to mix these hybrid spider,
or make spider collaborate
on one web on top
of the other web,
also, we say, oh, I
mean, let's start for
something more simple.
And then hopefully, the next,
we can make small hybrid.
But also was very complicated.
I mean, it was trial and
error, trial and error.
You know, it's like at least
the Black Widow, I think so,
I have seven different
types of threads.
One which is more
elastic, the other one who
have their configuration.
And was very complicated, too.
I mean, all the
threads, we will do
a system which is too flexible.
Was very difficult to calibrate.
This mean we make all the
lines are non-elastic.
But the nodes, and when
they connect, are elastic.
This means it gives some kind
of flexibility to the system,
still, to kind of
have this ability
to keep the nodes in the space.
It was very interesting that
you showed us the process
to arrive for example, to the
spider web project in a very
scientific method.
But I think that behind
that scientific method,
there's the desire of managing
the uncertainty of everything
that happens.
Not to really manipulate.
And also, it seems
kind of a contradiction
between the final
result of your work
with the way you show the
very scientific process, no?
In the middle.
And I think it's
detractive of it, no?
I mean, could you explain
how you manage in that long,
two years scanning
process of the web
with all these scientists
taking pictures.
And finally, when
you go and work.
Yeah.
Oh, I mean, it's
like I mean what
I start is like a
kind of a, I mean,
when you talk with
our [INAUDIBLE],,
you say, hey, I want to build
a spider web because I'm
interested in the universe.
And then I show the
Millennium simulation
that [? I acknowledge that ?]
I couldn't find
a spider who made the universe.
You know, like, I
have nothing to do
this analogy that others,
yes, give it for granted.
But at the same time, you know,
I come my way saying, hey,
but let's try it first.
Because you are saying that's
not similar, but actually,
you never even scan
it at this stage.
This means it's also
like a kind of a,
and now maybe we can compare
with a little bit more level
of precision between both.
And I kind of maybe explain
you, again, in a kind of.
But I will never put it.
I mean, once again,
it's like I'm not
interested to say, oh, I explain
to you in a scientific matter.
Or I just explain to you
in an artistic matter.
I think is what unified us is
this passion, this curiosity,
this interest.
It's like, oh, let's do it.
I don't care in the
way how I do it.
[INAUDIBLE] don't
ask myself how I do.
That's what I think should
kind of blur disciplines, also.
And blur the wish
of doing something.
I don't know.
That's as I find it, somehow.
Yeah.
But in that blur, you're
proposing new ways
of occupying space, no?
By the presence of
that structure that
constructs and somehow generates
a landscape that conditions,
that constrains, experience,
the way you inhabit it.
In the project in
Milan, you were
talking about the full social
experience of rebalancing,
of close the door, because
that different of pressure
was generating the
movement of people.
There's a full narrative
in that scientific process.
Yeah.
When I think it's like,
what the hell is space?
You know, I don't know.
That's the only problem
that I stop even before.
You know?
It's like, and then
I read string theory,
and then Brian Greene is always
explaining another dimension
because the spider
is able to walk
in a cable in a kind of
a multiple dimension.
Then I make the parabolic flight
that you're floating up there.
You know, it's like, I don't
know what the hell is space,
somehow.
And I don't know how
many damn dimension you
might be able to keep finding,
and expanding my imagination
to try, somehow, to
not even to translate,
but I think so to build together
kind of an imaginary capability
to expand also, the way
how we see the things.
And I think there is a lot of
influence, also, of the things
that then later come
up with something.
Which it may be talk a
lot about architecture
and how we navigate
on this space.
But for example, space
in the membranes,
not on these kind of
brains or whatever
we want to use more
this cosmic scale.
It doesn't exist.
Again, this lasagna,
it doesn't exist.
I'm fascinating about the
idea that you enter up here,
and you open it.
You open this space.
And then you move up here
and the space follows you.
I mean, that's, for me,
in architectural terms,
is fantastic.
It's a a space who does not
exist, that with my body,
it opened a space very,
very kind of perfect.
I don't want more
space than the one
that I need with my own weight.
Does it mean I open
it up, the space
follows me like a science
fiction movie [INAUDIBLE]..
I go and I'm like, oh, my god.
You know, it's like.
And then I think so
that I can open a space.
Oh, fancy enough.
Now come these guys,
and I close my space,
and I have to move
it to the other side.
I mean, what the hell is space?
You know.
I don't know.
But it's a pure negotiation
between you, the other one.
The other one who's on top.
The other one who
forgot the door open.
Because this is
what had happened.
Somehow you learn,
OK, that is space
is something that we can share.
That's something which, I
love the analogy to say,
invent all kind of
whatever architecture is.
But to try to kind
of promote this idea,
too, that yeah, when you're
a kid, you always walk alone.
When you're in a
bike, you bike alone.
Well, sometimes in a tandem.
But also, like, how much you can
invent a space which somehow,
this kind of very
straightforward influence
of the way how I move is
influence the way you move.
And how you move I move.
And I don't know.
That's something
which, the space
is all the time
invented and reinvented
by the way of how you interact
with each other somehow.
Maybe I get lost.
I don't know what I want to say.
But maybe it was
something [INAUDIBLE]..
Are you willing, at
any cost, to fulfill
this kind of experiments
that motivate
these kind of social
engagements without any friction
of geometry and those other
things that you hold dear
from your background
in architecture?
Yeah.
I'm always struggling
about geometry.
I love topology.
Let's put it in a
way that you can.
And I think so.
And all the
materials that I use,
somehow, they have
a kind of, and I
know the stone and kind
of $1 billion years
will change as an elastic.
But you know, for
example, the materials
that I work, let's say I
would like to call them like--
and also, it's kind of wrong to
try to say what I said before.
Because let's put it that way.
The same air that
you breathe somehow
influence the space that
you are navigating up there.
And I like the idea, you
know, when Fuller also
think about this
huge monster sphere,
it's just by one degree of
temperature between the inside
and the outside the
sphere will elevate.
Just mean, I'm trying
to transform something
in a very kind of
scale, which somehow
is, by the same
breathing of people,
the building will start to fly.
And then it's kind
of this, how much
the action of each
singular person
somehow doing maybe
something together,
it might change the way we learn
to live on the big Spaceship
Earth.
Let's put it that way.
But you know it's always,
I mean, the geometry.
For example, this
installation in Venice,
Galaxy Forming Like
a Drop of Water
on a Spider Web, which is
the title of this paper when
they try to explain the galaxy.
You know, each single
thread you have in mind.
It was these kind
of sphere, which
means that it was another
sphere, another sphere, all
made of elastics, no?
Does it mean when you pull
one thread, this feel,
let's put, this
geometry kind of deform.
It really depends
the tension that you
put in each single part, which
somehow, it compose something.
And again, it's beautiful
in the text of Latour.
This idea of composition.
Or it's something
that you build.
Or you put more pressure
in the membrane.
Which shape have the membrane?
It does not have a shape.
What I could tell you is
like, yes, have shapes.
But because this idea,
five people in the things,
they make this black hole
that you cannot go out.
But it's a shape which
all the time change,
constantly, constantly.
I mean, which
shape have the air?
Or you know, it's like.
I don't know.
I mean, you can
constrain somehow,
try to give it some dimension.
You've mentioned Latour
on a couple of occasions,
and yesterday, I believe,
you referred to Adorno.
And so naturally, there's
an intellectual framework
around which you build
some of your work.
We didn't get to
elaborate much on Adorno,
but immediately, I thought
from my own readings
about the critical function of
arts in its negational aspects
to reality as we know it.
You've resisted, on many
occasions in these discussions,
to codify, to categorize,
and to classify.
But at the same time,
lurking behind the scenes,
you're using art to instigate,
to resist something.
Can you clarify in
your mind, either
from an intellectual
pedigree, or from, again,
a more intuitive
motivation, what
do you think the
function of art is?
Can somebody help me?
[LAUGHTER]
I say I need help today.
You said I don't know.
I didn't.
Collective intelligence.
What was, was a
conversation, which
I have with Daniel Libeskind.
Actually, what had happened,
like architects somehow lately,
it was last week in Berlin.
And my wife is always
telling me, you see,
stick with architects.
That's the one who
are inviting you,
and I'm so glad that I'm
here thanks to you, right?
It's like, don't treat
bad your own discipline.
You know?
No, but besides,
I'm very grateful.
But no.
What I remember is like, I mean,
at least in today's art scene,
which I do not find maybe
so much the discourse
into the architecture,
is this capability
to the acceptance of
failure, which always Adorno
said is one of the [INAUDIBLE].
I mean it's something
that, [SPEAKING SPANISH],,
you cannot put it
as a condition,
but you cannot put
it anticipated,
not put it on front.
And I see many times into even
talking with artists mostly,
more than architecture.
Because maybe in art, maybe
because in architecture,
you have the responsibility
that is a building
that I have to stand.
That there is something, that
the failure is something that,
I mean, you cannot so
openly talk about it.
But in the art world,
you know sometimes,
and I'm trying to divide the
things that I didn't want to.
But was this mostly
acceptance to say,
well, it doesn't work well,
but you know, Adorno said,
it could fail.
And to be art, it have to fail.
This is one of the
responsibility of, no?
But you cannot put
it on the front.
And I think so mostly for
me is more the ability
to say, look, if I use
this pretext that it
might be allowed
to fail, I'm not
so persistent and consistent.
And kind of, this means,
it's something which I--
And this allowance to failure,
is it a matter of scale?
Because now you are thinking
about 1.2 kilometer dome,
flying structures.
You're getting dangerously
close to architecture, right?
Yes.
Of the universe.
Not of the cities.
We don't want you
to be an architect.
We want to stay
as you are, right?
But there's a scale
of intervention,
space modification of action,
that does not resist failure.
No, I mean what I do
is like, how beautiful.
I mean, and also, this was
a beautiful talk with you
the other day.
You know, it's like, there
is this kind of problem,
let's say, of scales, again.
But no.
This was nice the other
day when we were talking.
Like these kind of
1.2 miles diameter.
This from one side,
where it pushed me a lot
is like, hey, I want to make
it fly only with solar energy.
And the sphere in this
case is the best thing.
And here and there.
But somehow, you know,
I always thinking, like,
it would be so
beautiful that when
we think about a city
as an aggregate of very
simple and single houses.
And that's the scale.
Does it mean the
construction of the city
will be the wish of
each single individual,
you somehow generate
a big mountain.
But again is the participation
of each single individual
who somehow rely on the
responsibility of each of us
toward the construction
of something.
That has been a
city always, right?
Well, yes.
No!
That's what I would say.
Completely no.
That's what have been the
city of the neglected.
I mean, it's like, let's
say, my [? role, ?]
put it on the
architectural scale,
is like, how we could
engage people and citizens
and everybody engaging
the participation
of the urban planning.
How we can convince
all of you that it's
beautiful to build a city, and
how we can build it together.
Now it is in the hands
of developers, [SCOFFS],,
who sometimes make
horrible thing, money.
There is a kind of a whole
horrible scene behind it.
And very little people,
even architects,
do not have so much influence.
And for me, it's
about how we can
spread or try to engage
people into the construction
of a city?
In this case, a flying
city, but we could do also,
like, a normal city.
You know what I mean?
It's more about
invent the platform.
Let's say, how
beautiful it would
be if we managed to build
together as we did Linux,
or as this improving
Wikipedia knowledge,
we could somehow build a city.
That somehow, it's
like, go back more to,
let's say, Yona Friedman
architecture mobile.
And, you know, there
is a tradition, also,
into the architecture
scenario of trying
to involve the people into the
use or misuse of something.
And I think that's
really something
which I would love to see
more on a different scale.
Let me ask you this.
If MIT were to offer you the
commission of a new building
on campus with the full
engagement of our faculty
and student cohorts, would
you accept the commission?
Sure.
[LAUGHTER]
That's not even a question.
But I would try to convince
you to make it fly.
[LAUGHTER]
No, but I think there
will be no beautiful--
I mean, I would [INAUDIBLE].
Now we kind of start to breathe,
breathe, breathe, we go up,
we go up, we go up, this
kind of floating [INAUDIBLE]..
We exhale hot air somehow.
Or it's like a building.
You come up in the
morning and you say, oh,
which temperature is today?
And you see the building
is like so high or so low,
because it's like a
thermometer in the city which
goes up and down.
Or when you get
tired of MIT, you
can just take off and
go somewhere else.
But the other thing also,
what really drive me crazy
in Germany is now is getting
the winter and a bad weather.
This means sometimes
people come,
and so you go to Palma de
Mallorca, beautiful weather.
But something you
forgot it's like,
just a few kilometers above,
where the same spot you are,
is a super sunny day.
Not so far, right?
And then people
travel horizontally.
But the vertical component
is missing, somehow.
I tell you like a
very small story.
I was in St. Petersburg
for three weeks,
and there was no sun at all.
No sun, no sun, no sun.
Then I got in the
plane, finally out.
And then usually, in
Argentina, we still,
when the plane is
landing, we used to clap.
There is some kind of
sensibility for [INAUDIBLE]..
But when it happened,
the plane, it
crossed the level of the clouds,
and people started to clap.
They saw the sun, hey!
And then I say, oh, my god.
That's the first participant.
You know, with them, I
would not have problem
to convince them that I'm
doing a cloud [INAUDIBLE]..
Above the level of the cloud.
Tomas, you fly when you're
working with the public.
May I use this opportunity to
open questions to your public
out here?
There are two microphones,
one on this side
and one on the other side.
And help to open
up this discussion.
Thank you.
Thank you very much, Tomas.
This is fantastic.
I'm not an artist.
I'm not an architect.
I did see your
exhibit in Berlin.
And getting back to the
original question about who's
your audience.
To me, the audience
were the people
who were participating
in that exhibit.
Climbing into the
spheres, looking at it,
experiencing
unmitigated delight.
And I think that what's really
important for me, at least--
and I had no idea about your
background as an architect--
is your creation of
opportunities for delight.
For the--
For delight.
Delight.
No, delight as in--
delight, joy, whatever.
Ah, delight.
Si, si.
I'm sorry.
My English.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, yeah, that too.
The light as well.
And the other thing, even
about the spider web,
that was stunning to look.
At and sort of seeing
the dependencies
and interdependencies
among the various threads.
So examining or
experiencing your work
and thinking of from the
point of view of an audience,
from the point of
view of a participant,
you did mention social
participation to a degree.
But to me, that is like,
looms as number one,
and is what makes your work--
that I've seen and
that I read about,
the project you did Frankfurt
at the Russ Market--
extraordinary.
And I really hope that you
can continue to focus on that.
The issues around
whether it's architecture
or whether it's
whatever to me are,
this may be not the right thing
to say right now, irrelevant.
Your work takes my
breath away, and I'm just
like, touched by your work.
But I would like to
know how long someone
is able to occupy your space.
How long can you stay?
In--
In the web.
In which space?
In your space where
the people are.
I'm not sure.
That one, Italy, one
at the beginning?
Yeah, any one.
How many hours, days,
or, can someone--
I always thought this
museum during the night
did not have really
like a function.
And I say, why we
don't make it kind
of a hostel or a hotel
that people who go there?
It's like a huge mattress.
We could sleep all together.
But usually, I mean,
they have a timing.
It's like a half an hour
you can be up there.
And then otherwise, you know.
I don't know.
I don't know what
will happen, actually.
But there is a timing that you
get inside, you get a number,
and then for half an hour you
can be there, and then go down.
And then but always
we say like on the top
or one of the levels.
But on the bottom, you can
stay as long as you want.
This mean also, you know, my
mother never went up there,
you know.
And she always
[INAUDIBLE] up, down, yes.
Thank you.
In your conversation
with Nadia and Anton
before, you keep like resisting
your work from architecture.
So I'm just curious about,
because in your work,
you present a really strong
connection with architecture,
actually.
Like to share the idea of
social space, their gravity,
their public engagement.
And this idea has
just come across,
like the art in architecture.
And I'm just
wondering, how do you
think your previous architecture
education contributed
to your work?
Or in another way
put it, how do you
think your work will,
in turn, contribute
to other architectural approach?
I don't know so much.
But maybe you know
much better than me.
Maybe you can tell me.
I mean, we have been together
in the competition when we were
with [? Skyler ?] together?
No, you were not there.
No?
Oh no.
I forgot now.
I mixed it up.
But what should I have said?
I don't know.
Next!
[LAUGHTER]
No, but-- you're an architect?
Or you study architecture?
Yeah.
Yeah, super.
I hope, so, we can influence
each other all the time.
OK.
[INAUDIBLE]
We can build it together.
No, I mean, what was?
It's like, I was the
other day at a Media Lab
also trying to convince them
to help me on get some sense,
not to measure the
temperature of people
when they're up there.
Not because the Media
Lab, also, there
is this kind of strange
intersection, also,
of how they put all these
sensor on the building up there.
And then and how you
can track conversational
[? temperature. ?]
And that was, for me,
will be pretty useful too.
Because the problem is like
when you have to rescue someone.
But it never
happened yet, right?
But in case.
And also, it's like,
how much information
you give to the person to be
able to move into that space.
Now let's say on this
big air and moving.
I mean, usually,
what I always tend
to say is like, you don't
have to say nothing to them.
Let's put it that I'm trying
to answer your question
on architecture, no?
It's more about
which information
is necessary to
give it to somebody.
And if it's necessary to
use or misuse the space.
In that way, in that space
that was created, was there,
usually they are
very severe with me.
They tell, look,
the public first.
Take out your shoes, take out
everything from your pocket,
because it might make a hole
and you fall down 20 meters.
Don't go to the border.
Don't get together so much.
Don't do this, don't do that.
And at the end, it's
like, oh, my god.
Don't tell this to the people.
You know I hate this
kind of, it's a space
that you might experience.
And at the end, it's
contradictory, also,
with the same
nature of how people
might be able to
experience it, and to learn
from a kind of a feedback
relationship between us.
Or between how it's
used or misused.
I thought maybe with
a [? meal, ?] sensing.
And then it's much
more less responsible.
Because when you
enter the space--
and I'm always talking
about architecture--
and they tell you all the things
that you can do and you cannot
do, somehow you are enter
much more confident.
Because you say, oh, they
told me I can do this,
they told me I can do that.
And then you move.
The strategy I'm
always trying to avoid
is like, don't tell nothing
to, the participant.
When they enter there, they
are kind of, oh my god.
What the hell is going on?
You go [INAUDIBLE], you go down.
Like somehow, the
learning process
is much more your
responsibility toward the space
or toward the planet,
[INAUDIBLE] that way.
It's much more engaging,
and you work much better.
It's much more attuned.
It's much more sensible.
So I had a question
about, the talk
is called Beyond Materiality
and it's really fascinating.
But so basically, so this the
space, which is the negative,
then there's the solid object
which shapes the space.
And if it's beyond
materiality, is it
that materiality is [? wrap ?]
back around that the space is
the primary investigation?
And it seems like that's you're
really interested in the space.
But like Nadia
was talking about,
something has to shape
and define that space.
And so, for example
the plastic sheets
to find the different
layers, and how
people moved with the
space close behind you
was actually the mylar sheets
that would close behind you.
So the materiality,
is it just whatever
is needed to create
the environment?
Or is it just that whatever
you can get your hands on,
whatever is actually
does the job?
Like I think there
was a question
about what thickness
of thread you'd
use for the spider web was.
It just whatever was available?
Or you said, OK, this is too
elastic, this is too stiff,
so this one works.
So it's just, there was no kind
of overt thought about, well,
this is the material.
Just that, well, this is what
works best to define the space
and create the environment?
Yes.
No.
About material, I'm here,
I enjoy, also, at MIT.
I mean, we visit with
Leila, which was fantastic.
Many experts on
different materials.
For example, would be wonderful.
But these nanographene tubes
are not still available to buy.
Would love to have them.
I'm trying to build, now,
a flying [? plastic. ?]
There is this,
again this graphene.
These sheets very, very light.
If I will get these to
make a next solar balloon,
it will be much more
smaller, and need
less volume, less material,
but still is not available.
This is a negotiation, always.
I mean, the sheets
that I'm using,
PVC, would be nice to
make them with ETFE
which will last much longer.
I don't know if I answered
exactly the question, but.
Well, I guess it's just,
your main focus is the space.
Whatever shapes the space
it's whatever it needs to be.
Yes?
Yeah.
But let me put it again.
For example, in
Museo Aero Solar,
this kind of huge
museum, which fly
made of reused plastic bags.
Also the material over
there, you know, it's like,
people bring it, or people
tape it at their home.
And the space,
also, is something
which is pretty
undefined, because it's
due to collaboration
of the persons
that the space keep growing.
And the collection,
it keep growing.
And somehow, let's say
put it in architecture,
there's always this problem that
sometimes architecture build
a museum that is too
big for the collection,
or too small for
that collection.
And you know, you don't
have enough space.
Then you show these art and
you don't have to change.
I mean, it's beautiful.
This museum, somehow, always
show all the collection,
which is plastic bags, somehow.
And it keep growing, because
every time you add more,
it kind of get bigger
and get bigger.
And I think so.
And that's also
like a space which
just grow through the
participation of people.
Or get small.
Now, at the moment,
there are three museums.
One in Helsinki, one in
Italy, and one in Germany.
Sometimes what we do,
before there were many more,
and now we glue them all
together and the space,
it gets bigger.
As bigger it gets,
the more lift is.
There will be a moment maybe
we can carry a person up there,
also.
But it also change.
And I think it is also
nice to, when you see it,
you see every single piece.
Somehow you get the idea of
how it's done, somehow, maybe.
Of the materiality of it, no?
Which is, you get really
personal, somehow.
Over Santa Maria in
Colombia, Medellin.
And every situation of
culture or scenario, it
completely change, also,
how it's appropriated.
Somehow Santa
Maria was in charge
of many communities in
different favelas in Medellin.
And he say, oh, you
know, we will ask
and here worship with children.
And then they were kind of
using to make drawings on top.
And then everybody do something.
Then when we were
Minneapolis and San Luis,
because we wanted to let it fly.
And then we start to
work with somebody,
a retired person from NASA,
and then the FAA, Federal
Aeronautic Aviation.
To fly such a big
chunk of plastic,
you have to have a
way to bring it down.
This mean we build a sensor
to kind of [INAUDIBLE] it.
Also space, you know.
Because you have to fly but
not interfere with an airplane.
That's another space, you know.
The space you occupy.
Yeah.
I'd like to draw
attention to the fact
that in almost every
picture we've seen,
there's a human being.
And it might be like
an obvious fact,
but I think it's important to
stress it in the conversation.
Because it addresses,
also, the thing
of the audience,
the architecture,
and the materiality.
Because even in Venice with the
spiders, there's in the picture
that we saw, there's this
guy standing next to it
with little plastic
shoe protectors.
And the shoe protector
is creating a distance
from the floor, so that the
floor doesn't become a floor
by getting some dirt on it.
And so that we can still see the
white, which is the same white.
So that the man who is
looking at the thing
and is pondering this spider web
is like floating in that air.
So I seem to identify this
importance of the human being
that the balloon that is
floating with the sun, there's
somebody hanging.
There's always
somebody there being
floated by the [INAUDIBLE].
And so the question
of the materiality
is also related to this
presence of the human being.
Because the human being is
very real, very material,
very there, very physical.
And it is a whole
collection of devices
to bring this physical person
into a new material atmosphere.
Is that a conscious search?
Or is it something
that I'm just seeing?
No, no, I love people.
Still.
[CHUCKLES] No, no, no.
But I'm disappointed, you know.
I think tomorrow is, no, when
is the homage to Enrico Fermi?
That Friedman had--
Monday.
Monday, 3:30.
Somebody have wrote a book
based on one of the sentence
that he always said.
Where is everybody?
Right?
And then I will tell
you, now, a story
which kind of rephrased,
maybe the same, which I think
is a story by
[? Stanis ?] [INAUDIBLE]
written in Carl Sagan's book.
I don't know if it's Voyager
or some of the other one.
And then there are people on--
always about people,
I'm telling you-- there
are people on the planet Earth
trying to see if there is life
or there are other
people in another planet.
And then the first,
what they do,
there are some astronomers
[INAUDIBLE],, they
build the telescope
of that science, no?
And then they look and say,
oh, there is nobody up there.
Then next year, they build a
telescope a little bit bigger.
They look again, oh,
there is nobody up there.
Then the next year, they make it
a little bit bigger like this.
They look, and nothing.
And then the telescope keep
growing, growing, growing.
Now, there is a moment that
the telescope is so big
that the other ones see
first the telescope,
and we, through the
telescope, see the other one.
You know what I mean?
You know, and I
love this idea of,
it's again, where is everybody?
You know, I wish we might be
able to take into account more.
Even beyond this planet.
And maybe, I don't know.
Thank you.
I have a two-part question
about the spider web in Venice.
The first is a very MIT
kind of tech question,
and I'll ask the
other one later.
The structure, once
you have the map
of what the spider
did, and you have
your thing you
wish to create, you
have so many degrees of freedom.
It's very, very
difficult to make it.
So as you were
putting it together,
what was more important to you?
What was your priority?
The topology, in
other words, this node
is connected to this node
is connected to that node,
or where the node
ended up in space?
Well, that's another question.
No, I was pretty much
obsessed with trying to build
as perfect as possible.
You know, I don't know if I
answered the first question.
And then the other, I think so.
I always think it's
like, it was an exercise.
Just, I wanted this node
[INAUDIBLE] happy go here.
And from here, it go here.
So you kept going until
everything was right?
Yeah, I want to become
a kind of Spider Man.
OK.
So the second part of the
question is more philosophical.
For you, what was the most
important part of the art?
Developing the method to make
the spider web, or the finished
web?
The art, for me, was
really like to build
this web between
relationship with people.
Again, maybe the people
were not so visible.
But they can have a beautiful
spirit of collaboration
that we weave between us.
That was really the work.
Which is invisible, again.
But I think so that really
drives me completely.
I mean, was really beautiful.
Which is not even in the world.
But somehow show that this was
possible, thanks to something
which is unaccountable.
New friendship or
whatever it is.
But I think so that's really,
that's really the work.
I think so.
Thank you.
I have a question,
which is, you've
talked a lot about of the
importance of the sort
of social interaction,
and the sort
of people occupying the space.
But you've also
mentioned briefly
how the institutions where
you're placing these works
have asked you to
make compromises
in how people are using them.
When and how do you
decide what compromises
you're willing to make?
Is always a very, like
you sense it yourself,
until something they ask
you, no, no, no, no, then
one moment you explode
and say OK, basta,
I don't want to do it, you know.
But otherwise, you always
accept something, some note.
But mostly, the things
like what I try to do
is never being myself, and
then there is the institution.
And so we work together
right from the beginning.
Because mostly our
project, which are like,
it costs 30 times more
budget that they offer me.
I mean, if they don't want
to do it from their side,
it's almost impossible, right
from the beginning, to do it.
because it's really
like a, I mean,
they're very, very engaged
from the beginning.
Because usually, it's a
little bit more ambitious,
and there are these kind of
architecture scale in some
of them, which kind of also.
And sometimes the
institution, also, they're
not so used to work at that
scale, which also kind of get
a lot of trouble, also,
for curators and museum
and institutions, because
it's like, oh, my god.
And me also, somehow, because
I had never really practiced
architecture so straightforward.
It come together,
somehow, always.
So are you seeing your art is in
upping the budget thirty-fold?
[LAUGHTER]
Don't say this.
You said [INAUDIBLE] commission.
Well, we have time
for one more question,
and then we need to wrap it up.
Hi, hello.
OK.
I discovered you on
Sunday, and I'm not
affiliated with the school
or architecture at all.
So I see that your work
exists in outside space
and inside space.
Do you enjoy, or are
you more inspired by,
a space that's really vast
with so much potential?
Or do you enjoy the
limiting spaces that
are smaller or in interior?
Yeah.
No, both, I think so.
And always, you know, the
space inside your brain
is like a [INAUDIBLE].
There is always this analogy
also, the spider web,
I think so, we are visiting
somebody who is specializing
in [? connections ?] on Monday.
And then is kind of the
inner connectivity of cells.
And this means, I think so, it's
kind of this simultaneously,
you know, simultaneity
between the appreciation
of these multiple scales which
kind of make me enthusiastic.
And then when it doesn't
work on one scale,
I say, well, it might
work in some other scale
inside my brain, or inside
the brain of somebody else.
Or something like this.
Tomas, you've been very
generous with your time
and your thinking.
You're still here, so people
have more access to them.
I just want to thank you again
for this wonderful event.
Thanks to all of you.
[APPLAUSE]